in this video we'll talk about DNA
methylation DNA methylation is a process
of adding methyl group to the DNA
molecule and this is done by the DNA
methyl transfer as enzyme this is one
type of epigenetic modification now let
me tell you that biologically DNA
methylation is really important this is
involved in embryonic development
genomic imprinting X chromosome
inactivation and preserving the
chromosome stability also it is
important for cancer
now this is a particular Gene where you
can see promoter and the gene body both
promoter and Gene body can be methylated
but they have different outcome
generally promoter DNA methylation is
associated with repression of Gene
transcription whereas Gene body
methylation is associated with active
transcription
why this heterogeneity we have to
understand the complications in bit more
details
now the promoted methylation is
different in a tissue specific or cell
specific manner that simply means if we
have three different cell types and we
look at the promoter of Gene a it it is
possible that in let us say neuron the
gene a promoter is not methylated and
active whereas in fibroblast and in
epithelial cell even if the gene is
there but the promoter is methylated and
thereby that particular Gene a is
repressed this is one of the method by
which tissue specific gene expression
can be controlled
so what are the writers and erasers of
DNA methylation
so the writer of DNA methylation is
methyl transferences and the erasers are
demethylases
now DNA methyl transferases are super
important for embryonic development
because the dnmt1 null embryos
are showing developmental delay and
lethality also in context of a specific
transposon dnmt1 shows instability of
that transposon that leads to overall
problem in the genome
so DNA methyl transfer is one is really
important the other two components in
mammalian DNA methyl transfer is which
are DNA methyl transfer is 3A and 3L so
both of these are really important now
in this particular case the mutation of
these particular DNA methyl
transferences can lead to testicular
defects
my meiotic failure and infertility
DNA methylation during embryonic
development is a highly regulated
process now if we look at the
developmental time scale
when there are when there is a formation
of blastocyst the level of methylation
in the cpg island reduces dramatically
indeed in the early stages of embryonic
development the DNA methyl transfers is
are actually excluded from the nucleus
eventually when the blastocise gets
implanted there is an increase in
methylation so with differentiation
methylation is also increased
now the question is how DNA methylation
leads to gene silencing
so there are many ways by which
methylation can deactivate a gene or
repress a gene first of all it can
impede The Binding of transcriptional
regulators and RNA polymerase to the
active DNA regions
also it can attract mbds or methyl cpg
domain binding proteins which can
further recruit histone deacetylases
which lead to removal of acetylation
Mark and condensation of Chromatin it
can also recruit specific nucleosome
remodeler complexes polycombe repressor
complexes which can further condense the
chromatin and heterochromatinize the
particular region of that chromosome
this might lead to a gene silencing
besides the DNA methylation there is
also histone methylation which can
modulate gene expression in this video
we didn't look at the histone
methylation but in a separate video we
would talk about the histone methylation
I hope this was useful if you need more
notes and flashcards visit our Facebook
page you can support us via patreon or
by the super thanks option present in
the right hand corner of the videos you
can support via PayPal paytm or UPI
see you in next video